U.S President John F Kennedy was
assassinated in Dallas Texas on November
22 1963. within hours of his death a gun
was found in a nearby building and
police arrested the accused killer Lee
Harvey Oswald Oswald denied it I didn't
shoot anybody he said somebody had set
him up
but when the Dallas Police searched his
belongings they found these two photos
of Oswald posing in his backyard holding
the gun that killed the president
the photos definitively linked Oswald to
the murder weapon and made the case
against him airtight in the minds of
investigators but when they showed
Oswald the photos he insisted they were
fakes and that his head had been
superimposed onto someone else's body
frame him the next day Oswald was shot
to death while in police custody
sparking rumors that the US government
was covering up the real story of the
assassination and who else might be
involved and this photo which has been
scrutinized deconstructed and
reconstructed ever since is at the heart
of it
after Kennedy's assassination government
investigators spent 10 months compiling
evidence and concluded that Oswald alone
killed the president an explanation the
public has doubted ever since
conspiracy theorists argue that a
powerful entity like the KGB CIA Mafia
or Kennedy successor to the presidency
had to be involved in such a
high-profile murder and if these photos
are fake it suggests a far-reaching
conspiracy framed Oswald for a crime he
said he didn't commit or at least didn't
commit on his own
this is the most notorious of the
backyard photos it appeared on the cover
of Life magazine in February 1964 and
circulated in global newspapers people
were quick to notice something odd the
rifle on the cover of Life had a
telescopic site and in other news
outlets the scope was gone the news
outlets explained they retouched the
photo before Printing and inadvertently
altered the appearance of the rifle but
the controversy convinced people around
the world the photo was fake and of
course if it was fake now who faked
didn't why did they fake it and opens up
this whole can of worms this guy knows a
lot about photo fakes my name is Hani
Farid I'm a professor here at the
University of California Berkeley and I
specialize in digital imaging forensics
I work on criminal cases on civil cases
where the authenticity of an image or a
video has been called into question to
read is also the latest in a long line
of experts that have used science to try
to figure out if the photo of Lee Harvey
Oswald is real
oh that's amazing you have the original
oh that's beautiful so what is the
problem with this photo
okay first of all I assume I can keep
this
there were four things that people
consistently point to in the photo as
purported evidence and manipulation
first and foremost is people have argued
that the lighting and the shadows in the
photo are physically impossible in
particular if you look on the ground
there is this long Shadow to his right
but if you look on his face the Shadow
from his nose seems to be coming
directly down so people were saying oh
his head was spliced into a photo of
somebody else holding the gun and the
lighting was wrong that was number one
number two is a if you look at Oswald in
the photo he has this pretty bulky chin
it's quite broad but if you look at his
mug shots and other photos of him he
seems to have this very tapered chin so
that added to the evidence if you want
to call it that that this isn't really
his face that the chin seems to be too
broad the contradictory shadows and the
broad chin are the most commonly cited
signs of alleged tampering this Theory
even made its way into this scene in
Oliver Stone's 1991 film JFK starring
Gary Oldman as Oswald I never saw this
picture that is my best but my face has
been superimposed look at the way the
Shadows on the nose fall in a straight
line like it's High Noon a shadow down
here on the ground reads more like late
afternoon or early morning number three
is that in the photo the gun seems to be
shorter than the actual gun that was
used to kill the president and then
number four was that his posture seems
odd it seems like he's sort of leaning
back and he should be unstable holding
that gun like that like so when you look
at the photo yeah at first glance
something looks a little weird there and
so that's what has been around this
photo for a long time
[Music]
in the 1960s and 1970s forensic experts
tried just about everything to test the
authenticity of this photo examined it
at various exposures to check for signs
of tampering didn't find any photograph
the rifle that killed Kennedy at various
distances and angles to compare it to
the weapon in the backyard photo the
dimensions matched side-by-side analysis
with Oswald's mugshot confirmed it was
him they also took photos with Oswald's
seized camera to check if the unique
artifacts specific to the negatives
produced by that camera in this case
these 11 scratch marks would appear
across other photos they did meaning the
backyard photos were taken with Oswald's
camera investigators even recreated the
photo numerous times to see if the
shadow angles were possible in a single
image most successfully in this one
taken exactly four years after the
original at the same hour in Oswald's
former backyard the Shadows matched up
straight down on the face and at an
angle for the body they can included
again and again that the backyard photos
were taken with Oswald's camera and
there were no signs of fakery but even
presented with the facts the controversy
surrounding the photo persisted and I
think that is baked into conspiracies
anything that is inconsistent with your
core belief is simply evidence that that
person is part of the conspiracy to keep
information from you check out this mail
order videotape fake made by famous
conspiracy theorist and amateur
photographer Jack D white who was
obsessed with debunking the authenticity
of this photo let me show you the
results of my photo analysis and see if
you too can detect the graphics blenders
which prove that a powerful conspiracy
resulted in the death of President
Kennedy this guy was quoted in National
media as an expert and in a 1978 BBC
television documentary an actual
forensics expert felt confident that one
can only conclude that Oswald's head has
been stuck onto a chin
the flaw in these approaches is that
people tend to overestimate their
ability to determine real world physics
from a single two-dimensional image and
it turns out we're really really bad at
it when it comes to certain things like
Shadows like Reflections and mirrored
surfaces but if you think about it that
shouldn't be surprising this thing here
the visual system didn't evolve over
millions and millions of years to reason
about a flat piece of paper so Farid and
his team reconstructed the scene using
3D modeling software to rule out the
four problems of the photo the Shadows
the shape of the chin the length of the
gun and the posture
here's how they built it so we know a
couple of things about Oswald we know
how tall he was and what his weight was
around the time that he was arrested so
what you're seeing here is a
three-dimensional model that has been
scaled to his height in real world units
they added Oswald's known weight to the
model and posed it to match the stance
in the photo adding the weight of the
guns he's holding to test its balance
Oswald's mugshot provided a reference
for the narrow chin and shape of the
nose finally they lit the scene with a
single light source moving it around
until the Shadows looked just right you
can see how closely the 3D model matches
the original photo in this overlay image
it means that we have a
three-dimensional model of Oswald and
the Sun and the ground plane that is
consistent with whatever was happening
in that physical scene in 1963. now they
could examine the Shadows he has this
long Shadow down from his nose he has
this long shadow cast back into his
right and those are consistent with a
single light source so it just turns out
that Shadows sometimes look weird so
what happens to that very tapered chin
is it suddenly becomes very fat well why
it's actually not the shape of his chin
it's just a shadow so number two the
chin of Oswald is consistent with what
you see in the photo the gun which we
know the measurement of is perfectly
consistent with the photo there's
nothing wrong with it it's exactly the
right size and lastly the physics of the
pose you are stable standing up when
that Center of mass that projects
straight down onto the floor is
encompassed by your feet we have a 3D
model of Oswald we know where his mass
is we project that downward and what you
see here is that it is well within the
bounding area of the speed which means
the pose with the gun and the weird
backward tilt that he's doing is
perfectly physically plausible
some people might never let this photo
go but ultimately the simplest
explanation is usually the strongest I
think you've got to start to ask how
complicated is your explanation of what
happened is it plausible that in 1963
somebody manipulated a photo to be fully
consistent in a way that an analysis 50
years later cannot find evidence of
manipulation I do not find that a
compelling argument so when you start to
chip away that any artifact in the image
anything in the image that you think is
evidence of tampering that we can start
to now explain away at some point you
get to the end and you say okay the only
plausible explanation that is left is
that the image is authentic and now you
have to move on
I talked to another scientist Pawan
Sinha about light and shadows he's a
professor of visual neuroscience at MIT
and described a study he and his
colleagues designed to test just how bad
humans are at recognizing inconsistent
Lighting in images the subjects were
shown several pairs of Real World scenes
one digitally altered to introduce
lighting inconsistencies the other
unaltered they were instructed to spot
the original the test went like this two
seconds for the first image a gray
screen then two seconds for the second
image
people picked the right image only 50 of
the time upping the view time to 5
Seconds increase that rate to 70 but the
study concluded that humans just don't
naturally recognize illumination and
consistencies in images there's a link
to the paper in the description of this
video plus honey fareed's full study of
the Oswald photo along with everything
you need to read up on the
investigations into this photo over the
years